So, let's talk about the fabrication yield, which is,
what is the percentage of chips at the end
that we get to sell. So, the yield is
the number of working chips we get at the end
divided by the total number of chips that we
actually had on our wafer. We will see that the
size of the chip affects the yield. So, it
is not only that we get fewer chips when they're
big but also that a smaller percentage of them
work. So, let's say this is our wafer. And
the wafer, typically, has a few spots on it
that we call defects. It is either because the silicon
was impure to begin with or because there was
something wrong with the process at that place so,
in the end, once we get the manufacture wafer
pretty much through a given manufacture process, there will be
some number of expected defects per wafer. So,
let's say this wafer has two defects. let's
say that we divide this wafer into a lot of small chips. So, note that some
of the chips are not really complete, because
of the wafer roundness. We can only use
the complete ones. So, this is a good chip. So, we got 62 working chips, and
2 bad chips. So, our yield, is 62 out of 64, which
is about 97%. Now, let's start with the same wafer and the same defects, but now
let's have much larger chips. Now we have six working and two bad
chips. So, our yield is only 75%. So, not only did we get fewer chips
out of our expensive wafer, we also get a fewer percentage of them working.